salut c'est robert deniro pour Brut les gens
devraient s'exprimer ils doivent le faire quand les
choses empireront ils le feront
vraiment avec des manifestations de masse
[Musique]
c'est la diversité culturelle que nos
parents ses grands-parents ont apportée en
Amérique qui fait la force de cette
nation  et nous pouvons tous être fiers de notre
héritage
[Musique]
ils étaient ils étaient très heureux qu'un
soutien de tout ce que je voulais faire
surtout surtout si c'était dans les
arts je pense qu'ils le feraient ils le feraient
ils ne l'auraient peut-être pas été  aussi
heureux si j'étais quelque chose qui ne l'était pas
mais ils ne m'ont jamais encouragé ou
découragé de quelque façon que ce soit
[Musique]
quand j'étais enfant, je voyais Marty dans
le quartier où Marty vivait et je traînais
autour de lui et puis plus tard nous  les a
réunis peut-être dix ans après cela, qui
nous avons peut-être commencé à parler de Mean
Streets qu'il pensait faire
et c'est comme ça que tout a commencé
[Musique]
Je ne pense pas que je suis un père dur
comme certains pères peuvent le faire  Je pense que
mes enfants pourraient être mauvais
[Musique]
le 11 septembre 2001, ma propre ville à
New York, mon propre quartier de New York
a été attaqué et nous leur avons lancé
le Tribeca Film Festival en
signe d'espoir, de résilience et de
combats
Je ne suis pas sûr de ce que je cherche, je suis
juste tu sais que je suis assis là à regarder
les films et ensuite nous le
découvrirons tu sais mais je suis impatient de voir les
films de pas anxieux mais je  J'ai
hâte d'y être
alors que le nom dinero est synonyme de
dur à cuire son vrai don est la
sensibilité qu'il apporte à chaque rôle
[Musique]
Je me sens si profondément offensé par le
comportement de cette personne et ce qu'il a
fait pour démolir l'Amérique  ce sont
des institutions je suis très très préoccupé
par ce qui se passe dans ce pays
avec quelqu'un comme Trump vous regardez
d'autres dictateurs ils vous ressemblent beaucoup
maintenant nous avons un président gangsta qui
défie la loi et ce n'est pas bon pour
nous ça va  ça va ruiner ce
pays
[Musique]
toi